it's a maneuver I think driven by
weakness rather than strength because I
think if you're if you're a prime
minister you've just been elected by a
very very small number of people those
who voted you in the Conservative Party
and you're trying to do something for
which I would argue there is no mandate
because I don't think there's any
mandate for crashing out without a deal
on it's over the 31st and so he's
treating Parliament and therefore the
public with complete contempt and I
think it's gonna backfire on him I think
I think he's I think the risk with
Johnson has always been little overreach
and I think he may be doing it very very
early but isn't the idea within this
perhaps to face MPs in late October with
vote for the deal I've got now or there
will be no deal it's not necessarily
leading to no deal I don't believe
though that he's going to get a much
improved deal and I don't believe I mean
the public we've got to see through all
the kind of propaganda that you get
spewed out by the right-wing newspapers
he goes and sees Merkel she I mean I
watched the whole press conference she
was basically saying look if you've got
a clever idea let us know you've got 30
days and this is written as up as some
great concession same with macron now
listen they're gonna try to be nice to
him is the Prime Minister is the new
Prime Minister of the United Kingdom
we're an important country still but I
don't believe that he has a Monday for
No Deal and I don't believe he has a new
plan and his plan now therefore is to
try to just drive this through
Parliament and that partly is a bang but
I mean he does put those remain as in
Parliament and let's just call and
remained as the no know dealers because
there are plenty of people yeah amongst
them who would support a deal they just
don't want no deal puts him on the spot
doesn't it so how should they react well
they need to be put on the spot because
ultimately this whole campaign take back
control it was meant to be about
parliamentary sovereignty it was meant
to be about we've never had the European
Parliament / oh by the way we've had an
old Etonian Prime Minister tells an old
Italian cabinet minister resmoke to go
up and see the Queen and a Scottish
castle to shut down Parliament this is
not a very modern British approach I
wouldn't have thought so I think what
he's trying to do
yes is confront the MPs with some
difficult choices and it's time they
rose to it it's not that long ago Matt
Hancock amber rod Nicky Morgan all out
there saying that prorogation would be a
step too far and of course now they're
sitting around the cabin that's a ball
okay zoom to do nothing other MPs but
the test especially well in the cabin
I've got to stand up it was only
yesterday when those that opposed no
deal got together well most of them
anyway with Jeremy called in and decided
it was going to be the legal route they
were going to try to pass legislation in
the House of Commons that would become
effective before October the 31st and
force Boris Johnson to not allow No Deal
they've got the time for that now have
they the only way is so vote of
no-confidence they've got less time for
it they've got less dude I think you
said I think you can still be done I'm
actually I think the other way where
this my butt may backfire is that I
think some of those MPs in May you've
just been thinking maybe if I wait and
see and I'll just sit quietly I think
they realize now they've seen just how
prepared he is to do absolutely anything
including dragging the Queen into this
to get his way and I think some of them
I hope will be emboldened and actually
when Parliament does come back yes they
haven't got much time but you know the
fundamental questions haven't changed so
they they have got to stand up now and
be counted and start to answer those
questions so what do you think happens
next week then I don't know but I hope
that what emerges out of the process
that started yesterday I thought it was
good that the Jeremy Corbyn call that
meeting up there was good that people
sat around a table and decided look
whatever our differences and whatever we
said about each other in the past this
is what we've got to try and stop
because it is so bad for the country so
I hope that the MPs come back and yes
you're gonna have the Johnson people who
will just be saying you know gung-ho we
carry on but I think enough MPs ought to
get together and try to walk to the leg
delivery yes absolutely so fast forward
that process in two weeks well listen
it's as if that's all they've got that's
what they're going to have to try to do
and I think that you know I'm not a
constitutional expert but I've speaking
to people to spoken to people today you
are who say that it's difficult but not
impossible and if it does fail there for
propagation then all they've got is two
weeks in a bit yep and then in October
so
gotta then be avowedly no confidence has
it not and indeed install indifferent
governments otherwise Boris Johnson sits
it out and calls a general election
after October the 31st and it may be it
may be I don't know I can't read his
mind it may be that actually what he's
been planning the whole way through is a
generalization but just remember he
should reflect a little bit he may
consider himself to be a better
campaigner than treason may she's not
difficult but just remember what
happened to her she inhaled the
propaganda she believed that she was
invincible she went out to the country
and the country decided you know what we
don't like this and they decided not to
give up but isn't it all about what you
don't go through with No Deal everyone
believed and peace believe the European
Union believed that in her heart of
hearts tourism as Prime Minister would
not risk
No Deal brexit for the UK Boris Johnson
is showing MPs and the European Union
crucially that he is prepared to go
through with it
therefore aren't they more likely to
throw him some kind of concession in the
withdrawal agreement I'm not convinced
I'm not convinced but look they know as
he knows just how about No Deal would be
for this country and I think Tereza made
us have to say some responsibility for
this she legitimized No Deal in many
ways by constantly saying no deal better
than a bad deal I think most of the MPs
including a considerable number of
conservatives understand now that No
Deal would be a catastrophe understand
also that for all Michael Gove is
propaganda on this we are not ready for
it and therefore I still think that and
otherwise I want to lose faith in
parliamentary democracy that's what
we're meant because those is but isn't
this back to that point those that
believe No Deal would be a disaster may
well have the opportunity to vote for
another version of the deal that failed
to get through and that is the lesser of
two even he's into his same problems as
treason may had with these recent bogs
and his Baker's and his Ferraris and all
these people he's still worried about
that I think more than is about the
genuine national interest hmm but he
flips the DUP he gets 10 or 20 more
conservatives and it gets through well
we'll see but I honestly don't think
he's I don't that's his game I actually
my sense has been that he's
look he's a fight he's a campaigner he's
a gambler I think he wants an election I
think he thinks that he can destroy
Jeremy Corbyn an election and you know I
actually think the country is going to
be very very sassy about an election and
I think I think they would make him pay
a price